hi
[Music]
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a fantasy romantic comedy film
called penelope spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
the wilhearns are one of the wealthiest
and most prestigious families of nobles
they are respected by all in society but
not until the family's son named ralph
wilhern gets into an affair with their
housemate clara who turns out to be
pregnant he wants to marry clara but his
family laughs at the thought they want
him to marry someone from their own
social class and he obliges for the sake
of the family's name a heartbroken clara
commits suicide because of the betrayal
clara's mother is the town's witch who
is enraged by her daughter's death at
night she shows up at the wilhearnes
property and spreads animal guts all
over the lawn using her powers she binds
them with a spell and curses the next
wilhern daughter to be born with the
face of a pig she claims that only when
one of their own kind will claim the
girl as their own the curse will be
broken and her real face will be
revealed for the next five generations
all of wilhern's brides give birth to
sons
finally in the sixth generation a girl
is born to ella and leonard wilhern but
she doesn't have a pig face the family
celebrates thinking that the witch's
curse mustn't have worked but little do
they know ella has been cheating on
leonard so the daughter is not a wilhern
so the real firstborn wilhern girl is
penelope the daughter of jessica and
franklin wilhern the witch's curse has
worked on penelope and she is born with
a pig's nose and ears since the wilherns
are the talk of the town the birth of
the girl is heavily anticipated by the
media jessica doesn't want anyone to see
her daughter she even blinds a
reporter's eyes because he gets a
glimpse of her she fakes penelope's
death and then cremates her non-existent
body so that no one will ever try to
look at her face she then decides to
never let the girl go out until the
curse is broken they even talk to a
doctor about surgically removing the
nose and enhancing it but it turns out
that the carotid artery runs directly
through her nose so if it is cut
penelope will die jessica even stops
everyone in the house from ever eating
bacon no one was allowed to call
penelope a pig even if it was just a
joke little penelope would sometimes run
out to their main gate but jessica
didn't even allow that with no way to
get her daughter a normal face jessica
settles on finding the solution in a
traditional way since the witch said
that the curse would end when one of
their own kind accepts the girl jessica
believes it will go away once penelope
gets married to someone within their
social status she has been trying to
find a husband for her with the help of
a dating agent named wanda ever since
penelope's 18th birthday all the men she
has ever brought to meet penelope have
run away penelope has never been out of
her house and since the news of her
existence should be kept a secret the
men who come to see her are made to sign
a non-disclosure agreement after the
meeting the ones who run in fear after
seeing her face are brought back by the
family's butler named jake to sign the
nda it has been seven years but she
hasn't found a suitable man one day
edward humphrey vanderman iii the son of
a wealthy businessman comes to meet
penelope in the hopes of dating her but
when he gets a look at her face he runs
away horrified just like every other man
this time the butler jake is unable to
catch the man so jessica is distressed a
horrified edward goes to the police
station to report a demonic girl with
fangs trying to kill him but the police
don't take him seriously the wilherns
know how to stop the rumors from going
around so they publish an article about
edward being a delusional maniac the
next day edward goes to the newspaper
company and demands the news be removed
because it will affect his father's
reputation a journalist named lemon
hears edward shouting about the pig girl
and claims that he has also seen the
girl as it turns out lemon is the
reporter who jessica had blinded for
getting a glimpse of penelope he wants
to take revenge on the wilherns and
edward wants to gain his reputation back
so they join hands to expose penelope's
existence they plan to send a man as a
suitor and secretly take pictures of her
their only problem is that jessica only
looks for wealthy men so they cannot
bribe anyone with money lemon knows a
formerly wealthy and elite man named max
who spent all of his father's money on
gambling he can be disguised as wealthy
and sent to take the picture the
following day lemon approaches max who
agrees to do it after receiving the
money later they are in front of the
wilhearn's residence lemon makes max
wear a jacket with a camera fixed on it
which takes a picture when he raises his
right arm max and the other guys are
made to sit in the house's library that
has a one-way mirror and a microphone so
penelope can see and talk to the boys
without them seeing her max hides behind
the couch to adjust his camera when
penelope comes into the room all the
other guys run away in fear after seeing
her face but max who hasn't seen her
face stays penelope knew this would
happen so she isn't even sad anymore
suddenly she notices max is still
sitting on the couch through a camera
penelope is beyond surprised and goes to
talk to him through the one-way mirror
she finds him taking a book from the
shelf and putting it inside his jacket
max is startled when she calls out to
him and keeps the book on the table she
asks him if he saw her face and max
vagley says he has the two talk for a
while and bond but she never shows him
her face before max leaves penelope asks
him to come back tomorrow both wanda and
jessica who have been listening to the
conversation cry tears of happiness the
following day max meets lemon and edward
outside the wilhern's residence and
changes into the jacket again max goes
inside and waits for penelope in the
library again he gets bored and starts
whistling on a toy frog penelope
suddenly asks if he plays any
instruments he in turn asks her to guess
the wilhern set up a band with several
instruments in the library and make max
play them so that penelope can guess the
two laugh as max plays the instruments
horribly in the end he is playing the
piano while she instructs him from the
other side of the mirror suddenly max
feels a hand over his and turns around
he is shocked to see penelope's face for
the first time but he doesn't seem
disgusted or afraid rather he lifts his
arm to touch her face but accidentally
clicks a picture he curses at the fact
but penelope thinks it is because of her
face and runs away max tries to stop her
but when she doesn't he makes his way
outside instead of handing the camera to
lemon he respects penelope's privacy and
breaks it lemon and edward are furious
and ask for their money back just then
jessica and wanda come outside and see
max with lemon jessica figures that max
is a spy but max comes inside anyway
while the two talk max realizes that
jessica is looking for someone of their
social status because only he can break
the curse penelope appears on the stairs
and asks max if he will marry her and
help her break the curse to her dismay
max replies no at night penelope decides
to run away from the house to live her
life on her own accord she covers half
of her face with a scarf and sneaks out
through a window when jessica finds out
it is too late edward and lemon who had
been keeping an eye on the house also
find out about her running away
meanwhile penelope sees a crowd of
people for the first time she takes a
long walk in a park as she has always
wanted to and calls her mother for the
last time to say she isn't coming home
anymore she then enters a hotel to stay
for the night and pays using her
mother's card meanwhile lemon and edward
put out an advertisement in the
newspaper with a sketch of a penelope
look-alike claiming that whoever finds a
picture of such a girl will be rewarded
five thousand dollars penelope knows she
can't use her mother's card because it
can be traced back to her so she calls
lemon penelope wants to sell her own
picture for the money lemon and edward
are surprised but agree she takes a
picture of herself in a photo booth and
brings it to lemon the following day
penelope's picture is published in a
newspaper for the whole world to see
penelope then goes to a pub where she
meets a girl named annie and befriends
her annie gives her a ride on her bike
meanwhile max sees penelope's picture in
the newspaper and is furious at lemon
when he goes to confront him lemon tells
him that penelope sold the picture
herself and that she is declaring her
own independence the news makes max want
to pursue his dream of being a pianist
in a band again he goes to his old
friend and restarts playing the piano
cut to a few months later penelope has
been living her life to the fullest
going to circuses ice skating bars and
whatnot she sends her parents a postcard
every time she tries something new one
day her parents spot her while walking
through the city she tries running away
and ends up in the pub with annie an
exhausted penelope faints and the scarf
from her face is removed everyone sees
her face and is surprised when penelope
wakes up she is in a hospital bed
several reporters take her pictures and
she becomes the talk of the town in
contrast to what she had thought
penelope is loved by people and becomes
a celebrity herself for the next few
months she is all over the newspaper she
no longer needs to conceal her face from
anyone
edward however still sees penelope as a
hideous monster he mistakenly expresses
his feelings in front of the press and
angers his father to redeem his and his
father's image edward proposes to
penelope penelope accepts the proposal
after being persuaded by her mother
meanwhile lemon finds out that max has
been arrested for armed robbery and goes
to meet him in prison however he is
surprised to see max's friend with whom
he used to play poker he soon realizes
that he has mistaken max for the son of
a formerly wealthy man when he is
actually a normal guy with gambling
problems it turns out that his real name
is johnny martin and he had lied and
taken the job for money it is now the
day of the wedding lemon approaches
jessica and wanda to tell them that
edward was the one who published
penelope's picture they finally find out
that johnny said no to marrying penelope
because he knew he couldn't break the
curse as he isn't their kind even after
knowing this jessica insists on letting
edward marry penelope at the altar
penelope is asked if she takes edward as
her husband she goes silent for a while
and says she doesn't she then rushes
inside the house jessica follows her
saying that this is her only chance to
get rid of her ugly face penelope
retaliates and says she likes herself
how she is suddenly a force pushes her
and she falls unconscious when she wakes
up her nose has gone back to normal the
curse has been broken because by their
own kind the witch meant that she had to
be accepted by a wealthy aristocrat
which includes penelope herself if
jessica had taught penelope that she is
beautiful just the way she is the curse
would have been broken a long time ago
the following day wilhern's butler jake
walks out of the house with his luggage
as jessica yells at him to come back she
loses her voice
then it is revealed that jake is the
witch who had cursed the family and had
been watching them suffer all this time
penelope also leaves the wilhearnes
residence and starts working as an
elementary school horticulture teacher
one halloween she decides to meet johnny
again and goes to his house party with
annie she knocks on his door with a pig
snout mask on her face as they talk
johnny figures out that it is penelope
and the two finally kiss
sometime later we see the two telling
penelope's horticulture class about
their story lemon watches them from a
rowboat in the nearby lake he tries
snapping a picture of the new penelope
to write about it in the newspaper but
he sees how happy she is and cancels the
plan the movie gives us a beautiful
message that a person's real beauty is
not what their face looks like but has
to do with their kindness and who they
are on the inside like penelope many
women are made to feel insecure about
their unique features but in reality all
of them are beautiful in their own way
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching